a fascinating legal issue has come up
again in the derek chalvin trial
specifically with respect to third
degree murder now we've talked about
this in the past
on this channel third degree murder is
not as severe as second or first degree
murder where you're doing something that
is clearly going to injure other people
so it wasn't a surprise that prosecutors
charged shalvin with that particular
crime but there was language
in the minnesota statute that made it
seem like you had to direct that sort of
conduct towards multiple people you
couldn't direct that kind of conduct
towards one particular person well the
minnesota court of appeals stepped in
and said no that's not the case you can
actually direct it towards one
particular person and still be guilty of
third degree murder
andrew from opening arguments was right
he was leading the charge it said the
interpretation of this law that said you
couldn't direct it towards one person
didn't make any sense the minnesota
supreme court could still step in and
reverse the
court of appeals but it does appear that
chalvin was correctly charged with
third-degree murder and the jury will go
forward deliberating
on that particular charge go listen to
one of my favorite legal podcast opening
arguments or i will see you
in court